leute jetzt bekommen soll noch ein video
kurze frage an euch stellt euch mal vor
ihr habt ihr kind ihr habt nachwuchs wie
sollte man mit diesem kind umgehen
sollte man das kind in die schule
schicken und ihnen bei den hausaufgaben
helfen sollte man das kind möglichst
viel rum laufen lassen oder sollte man
darauf achten dass das kind möglichst
sportlich wird ihr habt sich vertan hat
das hilft mir bewusst schon denken kann
leute natürlich sind alle drei optionen
falsch ich hab euch ganz kurz mal ein
screenshot aus dem heutigen video die
richtige option wäre natürlich das
eigene kind an die heizung zu ketten
denn die dazugehörige folge zu hause in
gefangenschaft mein vater sportlich
einen letzten blick werfen leute und wir
werden einen komplett geisteskranken man
in action sehen wenn irgendwelche fragen
anregungen oder meinung habe gerne und
damit in die kommentare und wenn euch
dieses video gefallen natürlich lieber
freund wir denn jetzt los mit ja wir
legen jetzt damit los weiterhin unsere
verdauung zu arbeiten
[Musik]
platz ok stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp
eins nach dem anderen ok analyse wie
kommt man die situation also wir sehen
hier ein wohnzimmer wenn sie nach der
linken seite den vater ist die kappe auf
ok also erst schauen wir für die
sicherheit in dem haus zuständig gut zu
wissen auf der rechten seite sitzt auf
der couch etwas 1 geschichte seiner
tochter das verhältnis noch auch in
diesem raum da hinten steht irgendwie
gewehr auf der musikanlage direkt neben
der shisha was hat dich auch nicht zu
vernachlässigen ist leute ist dass der
vater einfach seine tochter mit dem
kommando platz anspricht platz also so
als wäre sie ein hund ja soweit läuft
das also mag ich kann es zwar gehen wir
nur das möchte ich dein handy nicht
zufällig kontrolliert würde ich von
design award mich sagt waren
okay okay okay gut wir müssen wissen die
story aufarbeiten leute okay also
scheinbar also die tochter wurde
scheinbar zu einer party eingeladen und
der vater hier geht natürlich wie ein
richtiger vater ist diese situation
machen sollte und zwar der kette tochter
erst mal die heizung weil sorry aber
eine einladung zu einer party was willst
du da machen wir das haus verlassen
willst du willst du außerhalb des hauses
spaß haben menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend
hast du das gefälligst zu tun
also wie gesagt ganze sache hier ist
schon mal komplett brawn gehabt ich weiß
gar nicht was ich mir dabei gedacht hat
dass es diesen typs security outfit
jemand also auch schon lustig drauf
steht weil ich habe ich gedacht okay das
unterstreicht zu seiner rolle als
derjenige der handschellen
dabei hat und leute so zu recht weist
und so aber ich weiß nicht so menschen
die in ihrem eigenen haus des security
kappe tragen die kann ich irgendwie
nicht so ganz ernst nehmen und verschämt
bedeute die tochter sieht ihren fehler
immer noch nicht ein natürlich ist es
ihre eigene persönliche schuld dass sie
zu einer party eingeladen wurde
sollen wir aber das kommt davon wenn man
mit leuten zeit verbringt irgendwann
kommt der punkt wo sie einen einladen zu
partys und dann wirst du halt zu getötet
ja da kann ich natürlich nicht
widersprechen also ich meine jeder
mensch der schon mal auf einer party war
weiß dass es genau so funktioniert jeder
einzelne mensch der eine party besucht
übrigens auch egal ob mann oder frau
kommt vollgepumpt mit drogen und
schwanger nach hause ich persönlich gehe
aktuell schon so eigentlich fast jede
woche feiern das heißt ich komme dann 52
mal im jahr schwanger nach hause
[Musik]
da finde ich gut finde ich gut dass er
sie noch mal beruhigt an der stelle
und dass sie ja auch noch mal klarmacht
und vor augen hält dass das wirklich
jetzt kein großer deal ist welche mal
ein sorry
weißt du jetzt etwa ja toll ist einfach
die jugend von heute leute einfach so
verweichlicht keine ahnung und dann
kommt man als vater war dahin und
kettete einfach die eigene tochter für
acht stunden an die heizung ja und ist
doch kein grund zu weisen eine sache zu
dieser folge ich glaube das ist eine
upload weil ich vor einiger zeit schon
mal eine youtube kacke davon gesehen
habe was ich habe ich die finde ja weil
youtube tacke hilf mir saß am
heizungsrohr das ist also wie youtube
hatte hilft mir saß ein weiteres wort
kann man es mal einziehen
[Musik]
ok also jetzt sind sie schon bei der 84
wir wissen ja leute also was an hilfe
folge gesehen hat dann ist alle
verfolgen sie gleich aufgebaut war also
ist immer so am anfang ist irgendwie
eine ganz absurde oder schlimme
situation die so die aufmerksamkeit vom
zuschauer fängt und dann die nächste
szene ist immer dass das opfer also die
personen der überträgt das passiert dann
bei der arbeit gezeigt wird und mit
irgend einem freund oder einer freundin
reden es ist wirklich immer das gleiche
art immer drauf ich kann gar nicht
hinhören leute nicht nur eine party
veranstaltet diese blonde ja diese
katastrophale einfluss ok sondern hat
auf dieser party auch noch einen jungen
kennen gelernt und ist dann vollgepumpt
mit drogen und schwanger nach hause
gekommen
ja tut mir leid dass ich nicht kommen
konnte zu einer party im sorry mein
vater hat mich an die heizung gekettet
und komplett behindert geboxt
wieso fotos von sich machen wie sie so
an die heizung gekettet ist wisst ihr
leute es gibt ja diesen schlag an leute
so vor allen dingen ich hab die vier
mädels so auf ins zu gern die so alles
zeigen müssen was sie machen also von
allem was sie machen will zunächst das
tor gemacht
bei happy place
[Musik]
stimmt ich weiß nicht also irgendwas was
sagt mir dass die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass es bei der nächsten party dabei
sein wirst ein bisschen geringer ist ich
kann aber ich komme nicht so ganz drauf
was es ist es könnte möglicherweise den
geistig gestörter vater sein der sich
physisch daran hindert das haus zu
verlassen
aber ich mir noch nicht ganz sicher wie
lange wollen sie noch die hände
schüttelte hallo die zeit stoppen wo von
jan ok fangen bei 318 stopp jetzt hört
auf eure hände das ist nicht cool okay
wir sind schon zehn sekunden vergangen
es reicht jetzt langsam stopp 17
sekunden händische wie lange soll das
noch gehen wahrscheinlich ist es sowieso
die intensivste interaktion die diese
fiona hier im leben mit irgendeinem
typen hatte das team jetzt einfach
gerade die hand gibt weil sonst nicht
einfach mal die heizung gekettet oder im
keller angebunden oder keine ahnung
deswegen genießt sie das gerade so zu
über den handschlag bislang raus 26 okay
wir können die zeit stoppen
43 das heißt sie haben exakt 22 sekunden
hände geschüttelt ich persönlich als
zuschauer ich denke da spricht sich auch
für euch leute muss an der stelle sagen
hilf mir bitte nein ich glaube dass das
nicht schön anzusehen das ist einfach
ist es einfach auf
[Musik]
okay heute jetzt allen ernstes ich muss
hier mal kurz dazwischen grätschen also
es geht soweit okay erst hat sie 22
sekunden lang mit diesem typen hände
gespielt und jetzt verlässt sie mit
diesem typen gemeinsam den ort an dem
sie gearbeitet haben
ich habe wirklich dass der vater erst
mal aufkreuzt und hier mal ein statement
macht okay also kann es nicht
weitergehen
ich bin sänger einer band mein absoluter
traumjob wieder mit den jungs richtig
groß raus kommen menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend jetzt jetzt jetzt
muss sowas muss anderes vor okay leute
endlich wird wieder für ordnung gesorgt
der chef ist wieder zurück mit seinem
absolut wahnsinnigen bahn also sorry
dieser part ist einfach geisteskrank
durch das wahlgesetz sieht aus als wäre
er wie so ein chinesische kriegsherr aus
dem achten jahrhundert oder so komplett
geistig gestörter mensch du bist
schwanger von ihm also der hat mich
angefasst also bis jetzt quasi also dass
jetzt plötzlich niesen arbeitskollegen
und meiner tochter
[Musik]
das war es natürlich erst mal mit 400
verschwindet jetzt erst mal für fünf
jahre im keller dementsprechen
verabschieden wir uns auch aus dieser
folge die sehr reich an
erziehungssystems war ich finde hier für
euch persönlich vorgestellt das video
hier oben kann amerika abonnieren danke
dass du schon leute sich versorgen
bis zum nächsten mal